[Musique]
oui
moi
parfois j'ai peur d'être enseveli sous
les rochers quand je descends je prie
afin de ne pas y rester pour toujours
les plongeurs savent des risques qu'ils
prennent il y a quelques mois après
l'arrivée du nouveau gouvernement on a
commencé à fermer les exploitations
minières légales comme illégale certains
se noie dans la bourre donc des masques
pour se protéger se lancer là les gens
ont besoin de travailler la natte à
l'exploitation aurifère est la seule
source de lyme qui dépendent de l'ordre
du traitement et de l'extraction de leur
manne vous disant que c'est plutôt un
travail à mort qu'un travail à vie
[Musique]
savvis je t'ai dit de rester collé au
bord mérité
non non non reviens c'est moi profond là
[Musique]
voilà parler et sarah calais est
surnommée la ville dort et il n'y a ici
beaucoup de montagne de terre qui
présente un potentiel ou l'extraction
d'or
greening sa petite comme à grande
échelle
on va sur des sites illégaux c'est ça
oui des sites illégaux des mineurs
plonge dans la boue qui aide les enfants
qui veulent aussi chercher de l'or ils
viennent à pied
il faut compter environ 3 4 heures de
marche wazers oui
[Musique]
avec talent
nous économiserons de l'argent quand
nous serons enfin payer j'aimais ce
travail mais plus maintenant
mes jambes sont enflées elles me font
très mal paraît pas avec d'autres
techniques
on y est presque ses proches très
proches
[Musique]
mais les gens avec l'aide de notre guide
khouya mox que j'ai rencontrés lorsque
je suis venu ici il y a quelques
semaines j'ai pu me rendre sur de
nombreux sites miniers qui n'ont pas
cessé de fonctionner estime enfin quand
vous construisez un nouveau puits il
faut compter trois jours pour comprendre
si les bombes
il ya de bons et de mauvais endroit
certains sont riches en or d'autres non
s'ils ne trouvent rien au fond ils vont
ailleurs combien de personnes
travaillent ici il y à peu près 20 puis
je dirais
une centaine ces gens cherchent de leurs
à l'abattée que font-ils
ces gens travaillent en équipe certains
creusent la terre d'autres la récupère
certains la lave et d'autre la tamise
nous passons six heures sous l'eau
comment savez vous ce qu'il faut prendre
si la terre est molle c'est qu'il n'ya
pas d'or il peut y avoir de l'or s'il ya
de la pierre comme ici c'est vraiment
dur il ya beaucoup d'autres sites comme
la par akale par étapes
ça existe dans d'autres barangay une
village c'est le travail le plus
dangereux que j'ai jamais fait la passe
et aux parents qu'aux s'il ya un
éboulement on est enterré vivant mais
personne ne pourrait nous sauver
bon ce noir et vite l'eau souterraine
est également très froides d'avoir des
six froides à l'axé presque
insupportable quelqu'un va plonger
on va voir
[Musique]
on met un tube dans la bouche pour
respirer il est attaché nous ne pouvons
pas le perdre
on utilise également des bouchons pour
empêcher l'eau et la boue de pénétrer
dans nos oreilles
et nous mettons des masques qui couvre
la moitié du visage et le nez
je m'appelle la polo garde m
j'ai élevé mes enfants avec l'argent que
j'ai gagné ici
c'est la seule source de revenus pour
mes amis et moi parfois quand vous êtes
au fond tami
vous sentez que c'est trop dangereux et
qu'il vaut mieux remonter l'arrivée
d'air il peut expliquer ce qu'il fait à
quoi ça sert pour vinassan
[Musique]
il a des problèmes pour obtenir de
l'aide parfois c'est effrayant
et si les parois s'effondrait vous
seriez ensevelies s'il est impossible de
vous remonter ils coupent leur ont tout
simplement la corde et voulait seront
sous l'eau c'est déjà arrivé à mon oncle
après ce qui est arrivé à votre oncle
vous n'avez pas peur d'être aussi un
sublime c'est moi un plongeur c'est
qu'il a déjà un pied dans la tombe
sympa mais pourquoi faire ça et pas
autre chose c'est de l'argent facile
sans argent on mange pas
[Musique]
les enfants nous aide malgré leur âge
ils font beaucoup
parfois nous partageons nos gains avec
eux
[Musique]
harold deux mois de l'eau il fait chaud
vite
mais pourquoi t'es pas à l'école
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas assez
d'argent pour acheter à manger
vous avez trouvé quelque chose
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que c'est je peux
voir seulement un palais juste s'ils
vont tout prendre comment tu t'appelles
à rolle hellip combien tu gagnes parfois
sans 15 pesos je donne tout à ma grand
mère mais le matin il ne reste rien
[Musique]
et nous revenons travailler ici avec toy
mon père est mort et ma mère s'est
remariée apple ma soeur a été vendu ils
ont vendu ma soeur qu'est ce qui s'est
passé avec mon père comment il est mort
il a bu du poison à cause de ma mère je
ne veux plus te voir maman tu nous a
laissé tout seul tu nous a abandonnés
tout nous a jetés dehors sous la pluie
un rôle dans ce bois demain d'accord tu
devrais aller à la maison
[Musique]
vous avez trouvé quelque chose ça fait
combien de temps que vous cherchez
depuis trois heures quelle est la
profondeur de la fosse environ 10 m donc
il n'ya pas d'or il faut creuser
davantage pour en trouver
si vous trouver de l'or comment vous le
partagez notre manager s'en occupent
chaque semaine mais les gens qui plonge
reçoivent plus le double ils reçoivent
le double bon c'est équitable alors
pourquoi aussi je m'appelle ebit de mais
ça je suis orpailleurs et un dessert
combien rapporte ans puis en moyenne par
jour habituellement 5 grammes par jour
et 5 grammes la nuit lorsqu'ils
travaillent en permanence
c'est difficile de devenir orpailleurs
il faut beaucoup d'argent
pas tant que ça vingt mille pesos
suffisant
de là à portée de ici on va le traiter
avec du mercure
[Musique]
nous ajoutons du mercure pour séparer
l'or une fois le mercure a ajouté nous
mettons le mélange dans un pot à lyon
ce n'est pas un mauvais pour la santé
seulement lorsque nous commençons à le
faire bouillir
c'est dangereux quand ça s'évapore nous
essayons de ne pas inhaler les vapeurs
[Musique]
wismar john madden amical
bonjour marie gianella
là il a faim il veut manger c'est bon là
c'est marina des sessions en chanter
white pourquoi tu ne travailles pas pour
une société minière officiel j'ai une
maladie de peau
il ne ment bougeront pas pour raisons
médicales j'ai commencé à travailler à
douze ans et cette maladie de peau est
apparu à 19
comment as tu compris qu'elle était liée
au travail dans les mines
je suis allé voir un médecin il ya
longtemps les démangeaisons ne cessez
pas c'est que je me grattais la peau et
les tâches se sont propagées à mes
cuisses et d'autres parties du corps
tout cela est dû à la pauvreté
je ne peux pas me permettre de me
soigner au détriment du bien-être de mon
enfant je ne peux pas faire ça on peut
tomber chez un médecin et tu pourras
nouveau travailler ce serait fantastique
oui merci ce qu'on sait combien il ya de
cas comme ça des gens qui ont eu des
problèmes de santé à cause du travail
dans les mines
j'en fais partie et moi même regardez là
vous pouvez me montrer un peu plus pour
qu'on puisse filmer c'est que je suis
timide
vous avez vu le docteur
non je me suis moi même j'ai tous tout
le temps vous avez dû le remarquer j'ai
attrapé ça dans les puits mais je m'en
fiche d'être malade obama m'attaquant si
vous devez mourir vous mourrez voilà
tout qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire d'autre
ici à part travailler dans les mines
c'est une très bonne question on se la
pose tout le temps
[Musique]
malheureusement c'est notre seul moyen
de subsistance
c'est illégal mais le gouvernement ferme
les yeux
si les policiers à trappes quelqu'un
nous laisse ou doyon tout simplement une
voie que notre vie est dure et nous
laisse repartir
[Musique]
- cinq en or il y a quelques mois avec
l'arrivée d'un nouveau gouvernement
ils ont lancé une campagne pour fermer
les petites et grandes entreprises
minières légales comme illégales afin
d'améliorer la qualité de vie à part à
calais assez cassis comme vous pouvez le
voir certains décident d'abandonner
existe toujours
certains disent qu'ils sont libres de
creuser parce que le propriétaire
foncier les ja autorisée surtout si
c'est un terrain privé et que le
propriétaire donne son autorisation pour
le gouvernement c'est assez difficile à
contrôler hu a mené vouloir après qu'il
ait été traité directement l'acheteur
vous avez souvent tous les soirs vous le
vendez combien d'habitude entre 800 et
1600 pesos logram
[Musique]
m
nous acheteurs ne paient pas beaucoup
ici c'est les rimes savons pas combien
le vendus mais autant que je sache les
clients vendre l'or à la banque à la
banque centrale c'est ça c'est une très
belle marque
on ne verra pas n'est ce pas non nous
enregistrons seulement votre voix vous
pouvez me dire ce que vous faites de
leurs après l'avoir acheté aux mineurs
nous l'utilisons pour la fabrication de
bijoux de colliers de bracelets des
accessoires accès
vous savez d'où il vient cette heure oui
oui comment elle savait vous j'ai vécu
ici presque toute ma vie donc je sais
d'où ça vient de ce que font les
philippins que pensez vous de la
fermeture des mines à l'heure actuelle
cela affectera notre entreprise d'une
manière ou d'une autre somme vous vivez
dans une région où il aurait aussi
important que pensez vous du fait qu'on
fernando mine
c'est triste mais nous devons chercher
d'autres solutions pour survivre le seul
bail n'attendez pas seulement avoir
recours alors là c'est ce que nous
devons faire maintenant nous qui lâche
ton nous sommes tout aussi inquiet
comment allons-nous survivre mais nous
devons aussi penser à l'avenir de nos
enfants
[Musique]
comment ça va commencer passer la visite
chez le médecin que vous ont-ils dit
docteur m'a donné ce médicament pour ma
peau
[Musique]
dit que même si la maladie ne se voit
plus sur ma peau elle est encore dans
mon organisme
qu'est ce qui est à l'origine de la
maladie
eh bien je passais mes journées dans
l'eau j'étais mouiller tout le temps
l'eau était sale je transpirais donc
c'est mon travail et c'est contagieux
c'est ce que dit le médecin
la maladie peut se propager par contact
direct avec d'autres personnes le jour
hier quand je t'ai vu jeter serrer la
main et que dois-je faire aujourd'hui
n'ont rien je me lave les mains
régulièrement
wa quels sont les risques à long terme
que représente l'exploitation minière
pour la santé l'année dernière nous
avons 260 cas de tuberculose et nous
arrive d'avoir des intoxications dues à
une exposition chronique au mercure le
mercure contamine l'air l'eau et même le
sol
des maladies chroniques comme la
pneumonie
la branche it hélas mans il y a beaucoup
de gens qui meurent à cause d'incidents
liés aux activités minières
il ya des noyades accidentelles d
explosion de dynamite
il ya également eu un cas
d'électrocution accidentelle si je ne me
trompe pas une fois un enfant de trois
ans qui s'est noyé dans une zone minière
car celle ci n'était pas correctement
clôturé elle avait tout simplement été
abandonné par les mineurs si je retourne
au travail je ne me remettrais pas de
cette maladie de peau parce que le
médecin est donc tu as fait ton choix ce
travail te permet de gagner plus mais tu
le feras plus pour rester en bonne santé
[Musique]
une fois que je serai guéri je
recommencerai peut-être je ne peux pas
dire pour le moment si je peux trouver
un autre emploi je n'y retournerai
certainement il participe à une
manifestation mardi
c'est la seule chance pour eux de faire
entendre leur voix il faut que le
gouvernement à manille entendre parler
des mineurs comme moi je comprends leur
sentiment d'impasse à la mêlée des cris
de la secrétaire jean alaux pesse
responsables pour l'activité minière
doivent être respectés c'est l'une des
façons de légaliser les mines à part à
calais mais pas seulement à parra
qu'elles sont partout aux philippines
il ya eu beaucoup de morts par exemple à
mabri n'a lopez ne comprend pas les
problèmes des petites mines des
travailleurs les riches dirige de
grandes entreprises et les gens comme
nous ne reçoivent que des miettes
nous n'avons rien d'autre et notre
travail dans les mines
nous y travaillons pour acheter du riz
et du lait ils les essais d'interdire ça
madame ça les gens sont en colère contre
moi ils ne comprennent pas que je fais
ce qu'on me dit de faire
rio avait reçu l'ordre de fermer les
mines
mais comment vous pouvez être sûr que
les mines et légales seront assez fermé
quelqu'un vérifie oui oui mais comment
vous faites pour vérifier ses actes je
me rends sur place
comment vous faites pour contrôler les
marchés noirs de leur essai invalidé la
suivante dans le cadre d'un projet de
ville minière ça mais les autorités
locales achètent qu'on leur bail
ensuite nous fixerons le juste prix
locaux et le gouvernement pourra en
tirer de l'argent tout en aidant les
habitants et les autorités locales
remettront leurs à la banque centrale
paraît même qu'il revendra
jésus miséricordieux
s'il te plaît tourne toi vers l'âme du
chrétien décédé dans le jardin de ta
prière prends pitié d'arnold
[Musique]
c'est ici qu'a vécu arnold sûrs sur 1
c'est là que son corps repose dans sa
propre maison
il est mort après avoir travaillé dans
les mines pendant de nombreuses années
son corps n'a pas été embaumée on
pouvait aussi attrapé cette maladie et
ils s'occupent de leurs pairs tous les
jours car construit mais je m'appelle
mildred riba je suis la veuve d'armand
nous reçoit à nous pour essayer
[Musique]
nous l'avons emmené à l'hôpital parce
qu'il avait du mal à respirer
combien de temps ça dure et combien de
jours six jours elle est en ligne
nous connaissons beaucoup de gens qui
sont morts comme huit appellent à la à
cause de problèmes de coût avec
catholique vient d'un pin ben abdellah
sa balle
[Musique]
alors la parole avec toi le matin vous
l'aviez astana
[Musique]
la même chose est arrivée à un ami à moi
il attend de mourir taille il n'a pas
les moyens de payer un traitement
travail dans les mines est notre seul
espoir
notre seule source de revenus donc je
suppose qui sait demain ou samedi
peut-être dans un mois il sera mort
[Musique]
enfin les gens ont besoin d'emplois
l'extraction de l'or est la seule source
de revenus
ils dépendent du traitement et de
l'extraction de l'or
[Musique]
harold mais sa vie
qu'est ce soit si le fils du premier
mariage d'arnold apparemment il ne peut
pas vivre avec sa belle-mère
comment t'appelles-tu qui s'appelle des
marques tu as quel âge
huit ans et cinq camions voitures tu
n'as ni maman ni papa c'est un pro vie
tu songes a dit qu'il le prendrait avec
lui nous lui avons demandé de le prendre
avec lui qui est son oncle mon mari il a
déjà vécu avec nous mais il est
tellement tu es tu un jour il revient à
la maison un autre il s'enfuit sans dire
un mot
je lui ai demandé s'il voulait commencer
l'école l'année prochaine mais il ne
veut pas si tu ne vas pas à l'école
il ne se passera rien de bon dans ta vie
rien dans ta vie ne changera si tu ne
vas pas à l'école tu comprends
[Musique]
où
la tension au travail je fais attention
c'est bien pour ça que je rentre en vie
à la maison
[Musique]
parfois il dit maman nous avons trouvé
beaucoup d'heures aujourd'hui la photo
n'est pas là je vais y passer la nuit
madame angot je ne veux pas qu'ils
restent ici j'ai tellement peur qu'il
lui arrive quelque chose où ma palme est
parfois je lui demande de ne pas y aller
mais il y va quand même
[Musique]
et me dit elle n'en avons plus de riz
maman assad et
hélas non ça me laisse pas aller
travailler avec ces gars là nasa
j'aimais bien ce travail mais plus
maintenant
non
et les gens montent en flèche elles me
font tellement mal
[Musique]